you know starting with the army of the
Dead basically why that's really
important is that this is the common
enemy this is like the bottom line this
is what everybody in the end is gonna
have to face Happy New Year everybody
so we have a whole bunch of Game of
Thrones to talk about even though it's
the holiday there's a bunch of stuff
happening behind the scenes there are
some new cast members as well as
returning cast members that we weren't
sure if they were coming back for a very
specific storyline in the north as well
as some of the bigger cast members
talking about the actual ending and
George RR Martin's holiday greetings so
if you are finding me for the first time
I do Game of Thrones every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything and I'm
also doing a book giveaway that I'll
explain at the end of the video starting
with the bigger characters first if you
remember during season seven episode one
we met a Lascar Stark and Ned umber sort
of the sons and daughters of the
disgraced houses that they had defeated
during the Battle of the bastards there
was this big argument about what to do
with them Sansa wanted to grant their
lands to people that actually fought for
them at the Battle of the bastards
rather than against them John didn't
want to hold these young people
accountable for the sins of their father
that'll probably come into play when
they find out that he's a secret
Targaryen but here's where it really
gets fun
so also granting them their lands back
because they also just happened to be
directly in the path of the knight king
in the army of the Dead is they slowly
wind their way south to Winterfell
but even if you haven't been following
the production and you've been more
focused on what's going on with King's
Landing the army of the Dead has to
physically march south through
Winterfell to get to the south the night
king can fly wherever he wants because
he has a vissarion but the actual army
itself snakes its way south as it grabs
as many bodies as possible added to the
army of the Dead so you look at the map
of the north here and you say ooh RIPD
Ned umber r.i.p last hearth because it's
the first big hold between east watch
and Winterfell but the car world is way
over here on the east coast and we know
that miguel supports neck isn't
directing an episode till episode 3
which sounds like it's going to be the
second battle for Winterfell so what are
they going to do with the last hearth in
the car hold it sounds like they'll be
added to the army of the Dead so it
sounds like we might get really quick
shots like we
at the end of episode 3 where they took
Highgarden like you saw a version of a
battle but it was Jamie rollin up with
his army you saw the quick shot of the
Queen of thorns looking out and then the
aftermath so they might do a version of
that for the last hearth in the car hold
just showing you the Nike and the army
of the Dead washing over those holds and
just making the army of the Dead even
bigger so that they build the
anticipation for that episode 3 battle
so we haven't talked about the dreadfort
but it's also kind of in this path here
if they snake down through the last
hearth go east to the karhold then down
around the dreadfort and straight to
Winterfell now there's hornwood there's
Ramsgate there's widows watch white
Harbor all these places down here so
just don't be surprised if the Rapid
Transit System of Westeros is in
operation because the army of the Dead
would take weeks and weeks to March from
different place to place but this sounds
like it's really only gonna be about 2
episodes before they make it to
Winterfell so now you kind of see the
logic and bringing back a Lascar Stark
and Ned umber they can give them this
really heroic death if they do want to
kill them but because they're so young
they might just keep them in that Great
Hall at Winterfell and have them give
orders to their subjects at these places
and have them redeem their households
that way the only other reason to have a
lot of scenes of those places like the
last hearth would be if that's where
torment and barracks show up because I
think we all expect that they've
survived so they could show up there
they could show up at Castle black or
rapid-transit style they could just wind
up at Winterfell at the end of the
second episode because if they're gonna
have a big battle on episode 3 it sounds
like they're gonna want to have all
their characters there by that time but
just remember even though you have all
the stuff that's happening in the north
before you ever get to a battle at
Winterfell there's only going to be six
episodes in Miguel's appacha nick is
directing that third episode David
Nutter is directing the first two
episodes so I'm expecting them to be
more character based so if we do have
big battles during those I'm just
expecting them to be treated the way we
saw them treat it during episode three
we did find out about an Irish actor
that's playing a new character called
Fergus so it sounds like he's going to
be a northern character we don't know
who he's playing he's not somebody from
the books so he might just show up at
Winterfell they have cast a number of
new minor characters for scenes up at
Winterfell just because
are gonna be spending so much time there
but we don't know exactly what's going
to be happening outside of the battles
and outside the main character reunions
it's a little easier to predict what's
going on with the main characters just
because you know them so well so there's
only a few things left for them to do
during the final season but speaking of
main characters Emilia Clarke has been
doing a bunch of interviews like the
rest of the main cast but she said
something really funny which I don't
necessarily believe but she said that
they actually do have multiple different
endings so no one main cast member like
the really big cast members know what
the actual ending is going to be the
reason why I don't think that's true is
because Dan and Dave knew what the
ending of Game of Thrones was going to
be a couple of years ago like they had a
plan they've been following that since
then so even though like little minor
things change within scenes like oh this
isn't working we need to change the
dialogue a little bit the really big
signpost like you're ending your big
action set-pieces
those were determined a long time ago
and they used to party with the main
cast members a lot talked about what the
future of their characters were so it's
very possible many nights Drunken years
ago they talked about the future of the
show with the cast members so even if
like there's little dialogue changes in
that final episode most of the main cast
members who are paying attention to that
kind of stuff have an idea for how the
show is going to end but because things
are so crazy there's a social media ban
on set like the actors aren't allowed to
use social media while they're filming
scenes which seems pretty logical they
just need to have something to tell
reporters when they're asked hey what's
the ending of Game of Thrones so they
can just read the HBO written dialogue
oh we don't know there's multiple
endings it could be anything they're
filming multiple endings when in reality
the actual ending will probably be
filmed indoors so even if they know what
it is nobody will have a chance to see
it like it's not gonna be something that
you could catch with a drone but let me
know in the comments do you actually
believe them when they talk about these
multiple endings that they're filming
because they've said that before like
kid Harrington said that and it turned
out to be a gross exaggeration I mean I
tripped myself up all over the place you
know I can't tell you anything all right
all I can tell you is that what you
might have seen on the Internet anyone
who follows it is that might not be true
it might be true but it also
might be true and you might be just
saying that to throw us off yes yep yeah
how many fake scenes were you personally
involved in 3 3 3 fake scene 3 fake
scenes how many hours of those fake
scenes take to shoot about 5 hours each
it really but over in book territory
George R Martin gave his annual holiday
greeting merry xmas happy New Year to my
friends and readers out there had a
lovely Christmas Day with friends and
family and Santa was very good to me I
hope the same is true to all of you so
he doesn't have any actual updates on
winds of winter I know we all still have
speculation on when it might drop
usually that proves out to not be true
so I try not to speculate too much on
release dates but if there's any big
news about that of course I'll post it
in a video leave all your requests for
season 8 or Game of Thrones related
videos in the comments below there is
some Ironborn that I was planning on
doing that I might post next week so
happy New Year everybody I'll say
congratulations to the latest book
giveaway winner Summa king please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round in
this video all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll name a winner when I
post new Game of Thrones click here to
learn more about what's going on with
the season 8 episodes and click here to
the actual release date thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight